let's turn our attention now to Iran
which has seen an eighth straight night
of protests sparked by the death of a
young woman detained by the country's
religious police crowds of protesters
gathered hours after counter
demonstrations backed by the government
the unrest has spread to towns and
cities across Iran activists say at
least 50 anti-government protesters have
been killed by Iranian Security Forces
[Applause]
anger among Iranian women is still
raging
everybody
burning the headscarves in defiance that
is unprecedented in the Islamic Republic
it began with the custodial death of
Masa amini a 22 year old Kurdish woman
arrested by Iran's so-called morality
police
dozens are believed to have been killed
in the unrest
the protests have spread to cities
around the world
here in Brussels Iranian women are
calling for change in their home country
the women of Iran they are not victim
and they are industry to say we never
been victim they try to make us as a
victim they try to control our body as
an object of sex they try to control our
sexuality or bodies for their ideology
for attack Theocratic regime we are to
say we are against Theocratic regime we
don't want this regime we want to
overthrow this regime master has become
a symbol of the oppression that women
have been facing in Iran for 43 years
it's different this time because the
country is United and they're all saying
together no more Islamic Republic of
Iran it's the Islamic Republic versus
Iran and we're here to support them to
do everything we can to be their
megaphone to be their Echo chamber
back in Tehran the regime is organizing
its own demonstrations
the protesters and rioters that took to
the streets are not ordinary people they
are trained groups that have entered our
country to destroy the ruling system we
definitely won't allow this to happen
[Music]
but there are fears that the state's
response could go beyond counter
protests
Iran's chief justice call for security
forces to respond to any further
anti-government protests with Force
foreign
Ed by Iran analyst Adnan tabatabai Adnan
just how significant are these protests
and are they somehow different this time
compared to mass protests in the past
what is really important I believe this
time around is that this is really about
socio-political grievances as the
starting point but of course other
grievances of economic hardship and lack
of any sort of political representation
of The Wider population are at the core
of these protests
and what about the response by the
Iranian government I mean how brutal do
you expect them to be what action do you
think they're going to take to quell
these protests
yeah unfortunately the longer these
protests
um are taking the more uh violence we
see on the streets
um I mean we've there are there's a lot
of anger in the air so to speak and then
vandalism happens other forms of clashes
and the more violent it it becomes the
more brutal the Crackdown will also be
so we have to expect an ugly scenery
unfortunately
but do you think there's any chance that
these protests will lead to any kind of
change in Iran
look the one thing that makes me
slightly hopeful is that at the very
very early beginning of this a lot of
current and former officials have
actually spoken out very critically
against the mandatory hijab or at least
its enforcement so if those voices
Prevail and I hope they do then we may
see some sort of gradual changes on that
front other than that I'm afraid that
these protests will be silenced and then
eventually come up again in this in the
next cycle
all right that was Iran analyst Adnan
tabatabai thank you so very much
my pleasure thank you